but I met a martyr and that's how I knew
um
that if you have the mental capacity to
be a drug addict that you have the
mental capacity to be sober it's only
people that are truly the only victims
don't have the option
to have an excuse even if it's a
justifiable excuse you know
and she was a true victim
I just wanted to be perfect and like you
know and there was that standard too I'm
from a really good family a family of
Educators both my parents are retired
teachers my dad's dead but you know my
mom was a natural born teacher and my
dad was a teacher and so I was the
teacher's daughter and you know I was
the daughter I got good grades and I was
the prodigal daughter that's what Mom
used to call me
um
you know and it was just this pressure
and it was pressure as I was there and
it was pressure that I put on myself and
I knew something I knew I had like these
problems I went into
preschool and I used to have this
Daydream I didn't I didn't realize till
pretty recently that this was um
probably really weird but I had this
this like fantasy where I would just sit
really still and if I sat still enough I
could just like shrink up inside of
myself
to the point of like a peanut and I used
to pretend that I could just stay steel
when I was out in public and disappear
and like my shell would be here but
nobody would know I was really gone
and you know to to have thoughts like
that all the time
while you know that like you're
you know a good student and a good
daughter and just you know a good girl
it was this this weird thing where like
I knew
um something wasn't right
but
I got good grades and I got a college
um a scholarship to like a really small
College in southern West Virginia but
the point is it was an academic
scholarship and you know I got good
grades all the way to college and I
didn't even smoke pot until I went
um went to college
but I believe this like lie that
um Wallflowers are told and it's like a
lie that's told by parents and society
and Hollywood like The Perks of Being
Wallflower which I love that movie but
that's it's [__] you know not
everybody finds themselves in college
and not everybody has this like
Awakening in college and not everybody
that didn't fit in in high school and
didn't fit in in middle school and feels
like they didn't fit in even if they had
friends you know not everybody just like
gets it together in college and that's
what I was banking on
um
it's like I put all my eggs in
the you know this college basket but it
was the only basket that I had because I
just didn't feel capable or able or
really I guess worthy of living life
um and I it just seemed like life was
easier for everybody else and people
would give me compliments
and I knew like that's not true you know
like my fourth grade teacher he was like
oh I don't have to worry about Jamie
she's going to be fine and I was
thinking in my head I was like how can I
be I'm not fine and it's like I try to
be
just like this perfect person and
I am a high strung perfectionist and a
neurotic perfectionist and a
self-destructive perfectionist and that
I just like cracked and I broke and I
snapped myself like under the weight of
all that effort you know
so anyway I went to college and
um
and
I I don't know I knew something I
thought I was just going to be like the
typical like sheltered daughter that
just like parties too hard but then
finds a passion
and all of a sudden I'm a senior I'm
entering my senior year of college and I
still didn't know what I wanted to do
and I had switched Majors like every
semester
and I still didn't know what I wanted to
do to do and pot
um
helped you know and it did help
and so I thought you know
if I'm just gonna party and I like made
this conscious decision to
to quit school
you know just to like dive head first
into
you know into drug use because Tom was
up like it was it was time to pick a
major and pick a career and like pull
myself up by the bootstraps and all that
like Hokey [__] that is such an
oversimplification it's like
it's not even like you know there's no
point in even saying it
so um
yeah you know if pot worked cocaine
worked better and it did and if you know
if cocaine works and smoking crack will
work better and it did and so there was
like just no I I just wanted to try
everything and needle dope was like you
know the creme de La Creme of escapism
and
so that's that's what I did
you know it was like until 21 it's like
I could
I could never be good enough to be good
and then from 21 to 34 it's like I could
never be you know bad enough to be happy
and I said that in my book and it was
like a real Epiphany to realize that
um
because that's that's what I just wanted
to be okay
and people would say like oh you're
wasting your life or I thought you were
too pretty to do this or too smart to be
doing that or from too good a family and
it's like well you know then what am I
supposed to do you know you tell me like
what because I'm like clearly missing
something and I and in my mind I was
like I [__] knew it I knew it that
everybody was wrong about me that I
wasn't going to get it together and like
be this successful person
because I knew I was messed up and I
told Mom and um growing up that I wanted
I was like I think I need to talk to
somebody you know because I knew
something wasn't right in my mind and I
just had this like
drive in this pool to self-destruct and
like nobody knew about this like
internal side of me or Secret side
and
I told her I wanted to go to a therapist
but this was in you know the late 90s
and the early 2000s
there's just
I don't know we just don't talk about
like that and then when I finally went
to a therapist I was already like had
these pending felony charges
and she sent me to a psychiatrist and I
told
I told them you know that I had been
like cutting myself for
seven years because I started cutting
myself in middle school at 13 and then
at 14 I got my first boyfriend and like
I guess you could say like the first two
drugs of choice was really like cutting
my body and dating because I was like a
Serial monogamous for 20 years and I I
wanted love to be the heel I died on you
know because everybody like wants a hill
to die on and why not
you know have it be with somebody
but you know now I know I was really
just codependent and
um a lot of people
take advantage you know a lot of guys
will want to take advantage of of
somebody that just has like this walking
stamp on their head that's like please
use me you know
um I was so attached like they I've been
a diagnosed love I although that's a
[__] term
but
so
you know
like
when I would cut when I first started
cutting myself
that was um
in eighth grade and I was in the shower
and this was in 1998 and I so there
wasn't like the term cutting there
wasn't like the internet like there is
today I didn't know that was something I
was going to do and I didn't know it was
really something people did
and I was shaving my legs and this
thought came into my mind and it was
just like you know what would happen if
you cut your leg and just to you know
just to watch it bleed and
it hit me like an epiphany
um it really did and when I I have two
like Cuts here
when I when I cut myself it was like all
of my mind and like this jumble of
nerves and emotions and I just was too
[__] self-conscious to
to live I was like clinically
self-conscious
and you know all this like anxiety and
emotions and
all this like Inferno of just
um stuff it was like laser focused on
the cut and the burn and the the ACT
and uh it was like this Macabre
meditation
and the way it hit me like like I was
meant to do that so I thought for a long
time that that's why I was like destined
to be a junkie like a true natural born
junkie because it was the only thing
that makes sense because I wasn't from
that broken home you know I didn't have
I wasn't molested or hurt or or anything
it was just like when your mind is the
problem and you don't love yourself and
you don't have a strong sense of self
when your mind's the problem it's like
you know that you're the problem because
you are your thoughts you know you're
not really like Eckhart Tolle says
you know our thoughts or the clouds but
we are the sky and that's beautiful but
at the time I didn't know that you know
and so my mind's the problem it's like
well you can't escape yourself you know
and
try as I might I just never never could
get far enough away from my head to be
okay
so when I met
when I met this guy
I was a full-blown IV drug addict from
age 21 until 25.
and the only thing that stopped me was
like pending felony charges and a felony
probation violation
and after 14 months in
of being locked up in 2010
when I got out I was sentenced to rehab
and I had this four-year period of
sobriety because I wanted to be okay I
wanted things to be different and
everybody in my family was just like oh
yeah that was a phase glad you know
that's over with
and you know I wanted to be okay
and so I went through the motions I
didn't know what I wanted to do or where
I wanted to go and I still had these
mental health problems
but I wanted to be okay so I just like
reverted back into
um
into what I was taught which is go back
to school go to school get good grades
like pay your taxes be a good citizen
and you'll be happy you know and that's
true for some people but that's
the traditional
you know path isn't
isn't doesn't work for everybody and it
worked for everybody in my family it
worked
you know everybody was able to live
except for me
so when I was sober
you know
um
I just wanted you know a family and a
life and
so I um I had my first daughter and then
that relationship ended because I was
still codependent although I didn't know
it at the time
and he had a lot of problems too we both
did
but when I went back to school I was
like oh my God you know I'm going back
I'm a I'm a new student an untraditional
student a single mother first time
and I just wanted to you know pass my
classes and be okay and when I made
um like the President's List I might I
got one b and it was actually in
substance abuse which is hilarious but I
was shooting dope at the time and nobody
knew it I had relapsed at the end of
this four-year period of sobriety you
know I had a bachelor's degree and
you know it was time to like
commit to a life like a normal life and
I just
I couldn't do it and that's like such a
misconception too about addicts and it's
like oh if when you want it bad enough
and it's like no that's not true you
know people want to be okay and even
when people are like oh I I like being
homeless because it's you know we're an
adoptable species
um
we're like highly adaptable but you know
you want to be okay you don't want to
have to like
stick a needle in your arm just so you
can like manage your emotions or feel
like you can exist in reality in a world
where there's like no place for you you
know as long as you're high like that
very real fact
um
you know kind of dissipates for a moment
so when I realized there was a period
where I was trying to juggle and like
sometimes I would you know just do
heroin when I relapse but like I said at
this point you know I have got my
college degree I have a job now it's it
was the one shot and I knew it it was my
one shot at having a normal job and it
was I have because I'm a drug felon in
West Virginia and Virginia it had to be
a job using my bachelor's degree that
was away from the two virginias
and you know there was only one
state which was Maryland where it was
like kind of that felt like an option
you know
um and so I was like four hours away
from my family I was in this new area
and when I relapse I would try to like
juggle when I was like try I would try
to be a functional addict and although
there's no such thing there's like
really no such thing with me being a
functional addict
and I was getting a subscription for
um a prescription for suboxone
and I was abusing my Suboxone and I shot
up Suboxone and it threw like dirty IV
practices
I gave myself MRSA
and I gave myself cellulitis too which
is why this hand is like permanently
puffy and purple because my whole arm
swelled up and I couldn't put my arm
down
like I had to hold it up and my fingers
were so swollen like they started to
crack and then I'll lift up my um my
bust and I lifted up my sleeve and it
was I could see my veins and it was
honestly terrifying like because it
looked it did it looked like a black
Sharpie somebody had drawn like a bare
Tree on my arm and it was the infection
in my blood
and
um I drove to the hospital and they were
like they ran a test and they were like
holy [__] you gave yourself MRSA this is
pretty bad we're gonna have to put you
on serious antibiotics now but you'll be
okay as long as you don't become septic
then it's then it's a coin toss that's
what they said they said then it's 50
50.
and I became septic
and they had a life airlift me like life
like me from one hospital to the other
which is that was the first time I was
like flighted
and the last thing I remember before I
woke up in the bigger hospital was the
um like the it was a man and woman that
was doing the helicopter that were
taking me and she said the only thing I
remember she said oh it's it's Friday
the 13th and it's a full moon mom didn't
want me to fly tonight and I remember
thinking like oh God that doesn't sound
good for me
and so yeah I woke up like four days
later in the ICU in a different hospital
and I was on a ventilator I had like
over 100 pounds of water weight my liver
my kidneys my organs was shut were
shutting down my body was like literally
dying
and they were having to
um check check to see if I had infection
that I got into the affected my heart
valves because the next step was open
heart surgery and they said okay it's 50
50. if we have to do open heart surgery
that's 50 52 and I was like oh my God
and
you know but luckily I I didn't have
open heart have to you know have open
heart surgery and after a month
of these liquid antibiotics for like
hours every day I started to turn around
but you know at that point it's like my
God you know I was
the timeline I was this perfect daughter
perfect student you know the perfect
everything to everyone
and you know then I was a drug addict
and then I had which I thought was like
the only option because option A like
doing the the right thing didn't lead to
any um fulfillment or happiness or peace
of mind or I I couldn't live with myself
and so I went like the total opposite
direction
and became a drug addict but now
I had had this four year period of
sobriety and you know have a college
degree and all this stuff
and my family knows that I've relapsed
in like the most epic way like they had
a call in the family like you know say
your goodbyes you're a [__] piece of
[__] [__] up daughter
um
you know my sister is a nurse and she
was like oh okay I see what you've done
here she immediately knew that it was
something I had accidentally done to
myself
and so I'm sitting in the hospital and
I'm like God
you know how am I supposed to be sober
now everybody knows I've relapsed
everybody knows I'm a screw up and that
things you know aren't going to go well
for me after all like why would I be
sober and it's not even like why but it
was like how you know how to live
obviously I can't do this so
that's when that kind of started to
honestly think I was like cursed or
something or that that was like a
distinct possibility
because
um you know like I said I'm just like a
natural Warren junkie that was my
mindset I was like I guess I'm my lot in
life is to be a cautionary tale for like
my immediate family members and somebody
has to be the cautionary Tale
you know and that was me
and it made sense because it didn't make
sense that I was an addict
um it didn't make sense because of my
background and I was like really good at
being phony and pretending to be okay
and you know
um
all this stuff
and I can't be okay so that's why it
made so much sense like
it's it's weird to have mental illness
because I guess this is how it is for
everybody kind of regardless but really
the the biggest it's not even the
bipolar
uh it's the um the borderline
personality disorder because it's like
your personality is literally disordered
it's just like your personality does not
play well with others
um
it's just strange because it's like you
feel like you have or I feel like I have
sometimes no control you know over
myself and
I have you know all these emotions and I
can see the good in people but you know
what did it matter I couldn't like be
okay existing in life
and it kind of led to this like
feeling like that self-destruction it
felt like fulfillment because it was
exciting and it was something to do and
it was like okay you know I'm in this
drug scene
um it was the only scene that I ever
actually felt a little comfortable in
you know because everybody that was
there and
and it was weird
um
I didn't like to talk about my family
like when I was locked up or when I was
homeless because everybody around me had
this horrible story you know like this
tragic story and
you know I felt shitty because
I didn't have I didn't have that you
know I didn't have that like awful
background or generational poverty I'm
from a two-parent household and my
parents did not even fight I have one
memory in over 50 years when dad died of
them having a true disagreement one they
had one argument in 50 years is what I'm
saying it's like amazing
um and you know so it wasn't my
background it was my mind
and that was kind of shameful to say
around people
you know and and the thing about like
pulling yourself up by the bootstraps is
you do have to do that in the sense that
you have to take charge of your life and
and and and Direction and get a focus
and focus on something that's not going
to kill you because you you know accept
yourself and value yourself enough to do
that
but
you know
it's like a dichotomy because
people that have
you know it's like when you start out
with so much in such a pile of like
festering [__] it's like really hard to
get out of that and there was this um
one of the youngest people I was locked
up with in the women's pod when I was um
you know on my way to prison for the one
time
she was one of the youngest people she
was like 18 or 19 and you know her mom
got her into prostitution and
just so and everybody knew that
everybody knew what a piece of [__] her
mom was and I was like God you know
she's like
she had like this immaturity and I was
like what kind of chance did she have
you know if you're born what kind of
chance do you have and then
when I met that woman who had the mind
of a child you know she was homeless on
the streets with me because because let
me back up and say
when they released me from the hospital
they were like okay you know you got
this and I was like no but you know I I
didn't want to leave I wanted to stay at
the hospital and just be there I mean I
I liked it because I knew it's like God
everybody knows and besides that I don't
I
I can't live life whether it's like
getting out of bed without wanting to
like cut yourself so you can streamline
your thoughts for like one second
or you know whatever it's like in
Drugstore Cowboy Matt Dillon says
something like you know I think it's
Drugstore Cowboy he's like oh you know
as poor junkies we have to do things
like put on our shoes you know and it
you know it's true
you know sometimes life is just like
more difficult but yeah I felt like a
piece of [__] because it didn't make
sense that it was so difficult for me
and
when I was released from the hospital I
was like already a full-blown
um
IV drug addict just from the people that
were you know coming to visit me that
obviously wasn't my family
and I was like man who who can you tell
like hey actually I haven't this wasn't
a rock bottom I had not learned my
lesson there's no lesson to learn
I'm I'm not functional and I'm a you
know a heroin addict when I couldn't
even leave the hospital it's like so
crazy but it's like you know how was I
gonna get sober then
it was like the worst time to get sober
that's what I was thinking so that's how
I became homeless after a few months
after that
you know because cat was out of the bag
and
it was just like going to be a thing
where we were going to stay me my my ex
we were going to stay like on the you
know around like where the peels were
for just like a week or two or figure
some things out but
um I felt like there wasn't anything to
figure out that I had tried to do the
right thing I gave it another shot and
four years later it's like okay this is
my lot in life and that's when I met
um this woman who had the mind of a
child and you know a small town
homelessness
there there wasn't that many of us it
was only like 10 of us
and she was the only one who didn't have
an addiction and it's like my God you're
this grown-ass woman and you're you're
so cute you just can be a cute little
figure cute face and you just had this
child's mind and and she had some
parents somewhere like how did she end
up on the streets it was like
[__] disgusting
um she was a smarter and I met her and
this old hoe was trying to pimp her out
and she was like here hold her for me
and she hands me this woman girl and by
the arm and she and she wanted me to
hold her while she went in the gas
station to get like a soda and
cigarettes and I was like what are you
doing and she was like this is going to
be good I think yeah let's let's do this
and make some money and
I was like man I come on you know and I
got her to my car and I was like
homeless and I was just really depressed
and
I just felt hopeless you know I was in a
bad relationship
I was
um you know I couldn't live life as an
adult I had tried it and so this was it
now there's like this woman who's like a
[__] child and these dirty old men
would just like they would all like be
wanting to be with her because it was
like a pederous dream because she was
like technically legal but I mean I
don't know if she even would be legal
because she couldn't consent to anything
and it's like where where were her
parents you know what type of chance did
she have you know she had no chance and
that's how I learned like
you know your mind is a factor and your
background's a factor but but at the
same time if you have the mental
capacity to be an addict then you have
the mental capacity
um to to not be to not be an addict and
because she didn't even have the the
option to like have an excuse and it was
just like
sickening I think about her a lot and
it's like I tried to get her
um
you know
I asked about like calling a number like
an adult protective services number you
know get some help and she uh she just
wanted to um she would smoke pot and
cigarettes and that would kind of like
help her mind and she just would cry
like she didn't want to go back she
didn't want to be locked up like an
animal
but um I don't know maybe I should have
like hauled but she didn't want me to
and I
I don't know and you know and they're
just gonna fail her because that's like
all the system does anyway it like fails
people
um who have like first you know failed
themselves but she didn't
have an option or have that opportunity
and I and I did and so that's why I was
like
you know uncomfortable talking about my
my family because
a lot of people didn't have it as good
as good as I did and when I went to
mental health professionals and
addiction professionals and all that
stuff they are business as well
and they really wanted to focus on the
bipolar because you can you know take a
take appeal for bipolar and they tried
Lexapro and lithium and something else
and finally after like a few months I
went to back to the psychiatrist and I
was like look I cannot feel my feelings
um I actually don't feel much of
anything
um you know I don't think this is normal
and she was like oh that's what normal
feels like and she said um this is like
exactly what she did she said hmm I
think you may be borderline
and but when she said that I didn't
think borderline personality disorder I
I knew I was codependent I knew I had
anxiety I knew I had this addiction to
to treat my mind
but I just didn't feel like bipolar was
was you know it for me and I think she
just wanted to give me appeal because
like that's the thing with borderline
you can't it's not a chemical imbalance
it's like a personality imbalance you
just have to like learn to live with
yourself and psychiatrists don't have
time for that so they just I don't know
I just never went back to her and I
don't take any like pills as a result of
that it just didn't work out for me
but
I was um
homeless
for that year and
when the guy that I was with who is my
ex-husband
when he got arrested
you know you're going to um
you're not going to have like a stable
relationship if you are homeless with
your partner and you're like doing sex
work to support two Habits Like a
relationship can't sustain that
and but but nevertheless you know he was
a person with me who was like going
through this
um thing with me and I'm a codependent
and I'm a love addict and we have this
history and
um
so it was like really hard for me to not
attach to people and not attach like
really tightly
and when he went to
um went to jail like my habit doubled
like in that in that hour my habit
doubled and I had never you know I
hadn't the third time I was strung out
after I got sick from her so that was
the first time I had like a heroin
connection and that was the difference
you know addiction only goes one way it
progresses and progresses
and so my addiction had progressed by
the third the time I you know got strung
out for the third time and became
homeless and I had this heroin
connection
and
um
you know I just knew like God I'm gonna
I'm gonna die in this like [__] town
that I cannot stand and nobody's even
going to know I'm dead or you know like
worse I'm gonna die like surrounded by
people who like the capacity
to care if I die or not
um
and so I called a message Mom and I
asked if she would take me to
to detox and it had been about 14 months
um
yeah
of you know that I was
you know on the
on the streets and
I asked her to take me to detox
because I wanted
to not die in southern West Virginia you
know I and
I knew I had to get sober to do that
I went to detox and
then I went to rehab for the second time
and it was the first time on my on my
own accord and even the fancy rehabs
like they don't
you know they just want to medicate you
I was I came out of rehab and I'm not
even kidding like on more drugs than
like I've ever been on it was just like
you know prescription drugs but my mind
was the problem and it didn't help me
um
like value myself or or feel okay like
nothing helped
you know that's how I met
um the guy that tried to kill me and
really you know he only did to me it was
a murder-suicide and he died and I
survived he cut both of her throats and
I lost half the blood in my body
and you know that was the start of me
learning how to live with myself
when he um cut my throat like I really
didn't think he would do it because we
were doing a lot of math at the time
and so I thought he was just like acting
weird
um by like doing this weird stuff and
like holding a knife to his neck like
you even when somebody's having a
psychotic break it's like you you think
they're not going to kill themselves
like nobody's going to Slit their throat
right in front of you let alone like
yours too and that's exactly what
happened and I I said to myself I was
like I'm not [__] dying today I'm not
dying in a in a trailer in the middle of
bum [__] nowhere with this guy that has
is trying to kill us
and when I woke up in the hospital the
second time I was like flighted
it's like I came to and I realized like
when I woke up I didn't open my eyes and
I could hear my mom she was talking to a
nurse behind me and she said is does she
know he's dead like and that's how I
found out Joe had died
and I had lived and I realized I was in
the hospital for a month
um he cut my my throat he almost cut my
hand off because it went down like that
and it cuts it here
and I have a lot of like defensive
wounds
um
but I was in the hospital for a month
then too and
it's like I was realizing that
um in fight or flight mode
I went into like fight or flight when he
was trying to kill us and
it took that happening and you know
meeting Joe and him trying to kill us
and going into fight or flight it took
all that for me to get out of my head in
a way that wasn't through like you know
chemical escapism
it was like the craziest
um sense of presence it's like I was in
the moment like literally for the first
time in my life at age 34 like as I was
like trying not to get killed and like
actively fighting this guy he had two
knives and I had none
and I'm looking back and I'm like
you know I was just going on this
instinct to live it's like the only
thing I was reacting on was this
instinct to live and it's like a
haunting Epiphany to be in the hospital
and having been so close to death so
many times that's not even counting like
overdoses like serious overdoses where
like you wake up in the back of an
ambulance and you know Narcan and all
that stuff divine intervention that was
my first overdose on fentanyl in 2008 it
was literal Divine literally Pulp
Fiction style divine intervention that I
lived
and um
foreign
all this stuff had happened but it took
him trying to kill us and it took this
like horrific thing for me to
um realize that I was like maybe worthy
of life and just because I didn't feel
able doesn't mean that that feeling is
valid it doesn't mean I'm actually
unable
to live or to love myself and so um
that's what started like my road to
recovery which is corny to say but it's
true
I like the scariest thing for me the
actual thing that gave me PTSD
um it wasn't like the blood it was like
this moment before he had the knife to
my throat he was behind me we were like
sitting down it was like a bear hug
stand off and he had his legs wrapped
around me and this knife to my throat
and he had done like that to put the
knife to his throat like this big ass
hunting knife was pointing to his throat
and um
it was the only it was the most fear I
hadn't really felt genuine Terror until
the split second right before he cut my
throat because I really didn't think he
was going to do it
and then it just dawned on me and it hit
me
um it hit me like this [__] wave
because there was like two minutes where
we were like at this standoff and I
thought like this isn't this is weird
but it's not he's not going to try to
kill us and um and I realized he was
right before he he did
um and it was like this everything in my
life led to that moment you know like I
had 20 years of dating from 14 to 34 of
dating like you know men that that
couldn't really love me because I didn't
love myself
and I had this lifetime of mental
illness in 13 years of addiction and
just like culminated in this Epiphany
like man he's going to try to kill me
you know this is um
this is it there's nothing I can do
about it nobody knows where I'm at
nobody knows what's happening you know
nobody knows anything and
you know this is it was the most scared
I ever was and as soon as he slipped my
throat I actually like went into uh
fight or flight mode
and
so so yeah
and you're doing okay now
um yeah I'm doing I'm I'll be that was
in July 19th of 2018 was when he tried
to
um kill us and he killed himself and I
do hope he can find the peace and death
that he couldn't find in life but I
couldn't
um
hate him or resent him for I'm only
trying to do to me what I had like tried
to do to myself for so long you know
because he was like a victim of himself
that day and I was like nearly a victim
of myself
but yeah that's what started it
um did it take something that extreme
for you to finally wake up to your
self-destructive oh yeah I mean and and
it was it was as Extreme as it had to be
you know because overdoses wouldn't work
and homelessness and felonies like
nothing nothing would work because
um
I didn't think I was worthy of living so
it was like whatever happens you know
happens I was like ready to die I was
sure I like could feel it in my bones
that I was ready to die because you know
it's like I'm Gonna Get High Till the
[__] day I die it was like this
Mantra because I didn't know what else
to do you know so it didn't matter that
it was synthetic or fleeting whether it
was a guy or you know heroin or whatever
it didn't matter it was just like
something in the moment that made me
feel okay
and if he hadn't done that I don't think
I'd be alive today you know
um because I wouldn't have gone into
flight or flight mode and I wouldn't
have realized
that I'm not you know these thoughts and
feelings you know they're
like I'm I'm worthy of life because I'm
alive so I just have to find out like
why why that is
you know what do you think it is about
being born are you more borderline or
bipolar or both both yeah what do you
think it is about that that just
keeps you from wanting to realize your
potential and just just live a great
life and accept great things in your
life it's like you know if your
personality and your mind you know Works
differently it's easy to think
that you're just broken you know because
the way isn't necessary that's going to
work isn't going to necessarily be the
same the same direction and so I just
felt like I didn't
fit in anywhere you know I hated being a
human I hated being in my body
I hated being in reality I was one of
those four-year-olds that cried when I
had to poop I cried when I had to throw
up like I was just like fearful of life
because
um because I couldn't you know accept
that
I just have to like go my own way you
know it's like you just want to draw in
um all these emotions like as long as
they're like
you know anger side like
if as long as it was just like
you know going to allow me to feel
something that was enough you know
because it's easy to like conflate
passion with love and danger for
excitement
um you know if you can't exist just as
is and I think that's part of the reason
why you know
oh God I'm a [__] nervous wreck Mark
I really am you're doing fine though
okay your life is tell me about your
life today
well
um
I have had to start so when I was in the
hospital I was like okay I have got to
try I have got to try to do I don't know
how I'm gonna live
and I have like Hotmail I'm so nervous
but I I don't know how to live I don't
know what I'm doing I have failed
epically I'm in my mid [__] 30s and
I'm still like it's so sad I was almost
killed by a guy but it was the same
[__] as when I was 14. you know it
was 20 literally 20 years of just like
talking on the phone to a guy who just
said all the right things and me I could
just feel myself like giving up any
little shred of myself that I had to
this relationship because it felt like a
path in a way so I had all these like a
string of failures for for a lifetime
and so I had to really
just look at like accept myself like as
is and and work on that you know and as
someone who hated themselves and hated
life and I didn't fit in with my family
with the Catholic church with this small
town
um I just felt like I never fit I didn't
fit with college like I said the the
drug scene
was the only place I felt like people
got it because even if you did you
weren't from a broken home or you were
from a broken home it still was like
this unspoken camaraderie of like okay
you know you get it it's like you cannot
[__] exist and function without you
know some type of enhancements and it's
all like to feel more or feel or like
feel less or just like to feel period
you know
um so I had to to look at myself as like
kind of like this Trinity I broke myself
up into mind body and spirit which I
think we all are kind of gods and
goddesses in that way like we're all a
Holy Trinity and I started to really be
um
selfish in the right ways and people say
drug addicts are selfish and that's
[__] you know you're because
addiction
um
it's like this parasite on your heart
and a parasite in your soul and it like
latches on and you don't do anything for
yourself if you're a drug addict you do
it for your you know for this addiction
that has taken you over so it's actually
like you're very you know you're not
selfish at all in that way
and I begin to really like act
um selfishly in the right way and I
really worked on like radical
self-acceptance and self-love and
compassion
um when I was homeless we squatted in
this house this abandoned house it was a
hoarder house a former hoarder house it
was horrific
and I stayed in this little girl's room
and she had it painted in Alice in
Wonderland mural and in the midst of
this [__] old ass empty it was
abandoned but it wasn't empty hoarder
housed there was this beautiful bedroom
with an Alice in Wonderland like mural
scene and that's where I was sleeping
and
Scotch tape to the wall it said um it
was a fortune cookie that she had taped
it said your heart is your greatest
asset and I kept that fortune cookie
until
um
the cops or the HazMat team or whoever
had to throw it away because it was like
drenched in blood
um from the murder suicide but I had
that fortune cookie the whole you know
that whole time
I think uh 14 months
and it's you know I just had to learn
that it's not that my heart was too big
or that I was too emotional or too
caring or to anything I just had to
learn to live with myself and accept
that
so um I started journaling and in two
months I cured my PTSD and so now I have
a focus like of trying to actually get
my writing out into the world and you
know it's weird because I think it's
pretty good and
just in summary the last thing I got a
dog dogs are like the key to life I
thought it was a cat person so I say
that with a heavy heart but it's true
dogs are better
um
you know it's just like in summary
I would have
um just like it's it's weird to realize
that you deserve life you know and you
deserve to live and you deserve to be
happy and you have something to
contribute because I didn't start
writing and I didn't really feel like
okay this is something I'm good at I
didn't I was not good at anything
um for for so long and that's how I felt
and it's just like Eerie to think about
being so close to death for so long
and you know how many people are gonna
die you know without even knowing that
they like have something to offer and
that they deserve happiness you know
it's really it's really depressing to
think about but
there's uh all right Jamie thank you so
much all right thank you